now Rhonda Sanders has done something
very cruel yeah it's horrible it's
really horrible because what he did was
he sent a bunch of migrants to Martha's
Vineyard the season's over
are you like nuts
it's after Labor Day it's after
September first of all I have friends on
the vineyard I have friends on the cape
I have friends in Nantucket I have
friends in the Hamptons the season is
memorial through Labor stop it don't be
silly
yes fall is lovely in all of these
places and a small select group of
people will hang out you know because
work is more remote now and there's
nothing wrong with a winery a Vineyard
tour in the Hamptons in the fall or a
beautiful but but for the most part if
you want to get
really the full character of the area
dropped them off in the beginning of
Summer
so I don't get it
fall everybody spends in New York City
and then of course winter everybody goes
to Aspen or if they don't like the or
Jackson Hole or Telluride or [ __ ]
Breckenridge and if you don't like the
cold you have Saint barths and Anguilla
there's options why send them off season
to the vineyard it's cruel
I mean it's fine
it's not horrible clearly
but it's just not you know what I mean
like all the good parties are over all
the fun networking's done all you know
what I mean like all of the kind of
Summer Vibes the swimming the swimming
and The Vibes aren't happening like
so it's crazy it's so weird to me to
send like it's not a guy's a psychotic
[ __ ] it's like your people come to this
country and it's like okay The Vibes
right now are like pumpkins Fall New
England
calling somebody up at an Ivy League
school you haven't [ __ ] in a while and
going up to see them taking them to like
an old creaky in getting drunk drinking
mulled cider you know this is the thing
rainy days kind of like the vibe right
now is very much like I'm like LARPing
as a poor person kind of like it's like
big sweatshirts and hats and old jeans
and oh look I'm by the railroad now
photo you know what I mean and it's like
the family's con it's like getting our
adderall addiction kind of within range
because there is a shortage and then
just focusing on the holidays and like
what am I gonna be for Halloween where
am I gonna go like
it's like you're cannibalizing people's
Italy photos on Instagram and you're mad
at that still because they in late
August everybody was in Italy even Luis
Gomez
so it's just it angers me so it's like
so to bring these migrants
to Martha's Vineyard off season isn't
the deal like you explain to them
they're like the fall is like it's a
thing here it's a thing it's Halloween
it's New England it's sexy it's fun it's
you know what I mean like and and like
and then like explain to them like how
it works like how the social order
operates
now where do they now where do they go
because Mark this Vineyard
nicely because more this Vineyard gets
it got rid of them because mother's
Vineyard goes we're not at our best
right now we are literally preparing for
next year
and then and then Martha's Vineyard sent
them somewhere else Palm Beach where do
they go I believe they went to Cape Cod
Cape Cod okay but the reality is it's
like
late fall through the spring it's Palm
Beach
it's not
like what's wrong I don't get it
whatever I'm just here's my whole thing
with migrants
my whole thing with migrants has always
been If You're Gonna Come
you have to assimilate into the culture
and the culture is
Hampton's Vineyard summer
Palm Beach Miami winter New York Spring
New York Fall New York Spring
potentially this is the culture
assimilate into the culture
duh
this is my biggest issue
immigrants come over here and they're
like oh we're just gonna go to Martha's
Vineyard in the fall it's like no you're
not
you have to assimilate into our culture
dummies
everybody goes to their second beach
house
in in like late June or even early July
they do the summer July to like the
second week of August then everybody
goes to Europe
wake up
so if these migrants don't want to like
fall in line then I don't know I don't
know
what's the point
are they nuts
what were they even doing there
I mean here's the deal if they're
looking at houses I can't be mad at them
to look at houses in the because you
want to look off season and you don't it
doesn't want to be too hot you don't
want to deal with traffic so if you're
looking if these migrants are looking at
houses off season trying to make a deal
I'm not mad at them I'm not mad at them
I'm literally not mad at them now were
you looking at homes I got my eye on a
few
the thing with the vineyard and I have
to explain this to them every migrant I
meet I have to explain to them I go
start start somewhere closer start on
the cape like the vineyard's a thing
it's just its own thing it's like
Nantucket like when I see a migrant I go
I know you want to live in Nantucket but
it's so far it's older money it's more
Finance like you just and they go okay
and I go listen to what I'm saying to
you
[Laughter]
that's the whole thing it's like these
migrants like I respect the Hustle but
you have to understand The Vineyards its
own Vibe it's its own thing it's not
forever I'm a Hamptons person
you might be a Vineyard person you might
be an Nantucket person you might go to
Crete you might go to Mykonos like no
one's judging where you spend your
Summers
but you have to experiment with a bunch
of different things
Here's a thought
Rent First
[Laughter]
migrants
listen to me don't make the mistake that
so many people have made
rent first it is a lot of money but you
understand like what you like what you
don't like
it's it's so simple it's like so many
people commit like I have a friend that
just bought them against and they're
like oh my God it's so far I was like
why didn't you rent in South First
why didn't you rent first you just
so I get so terrified for migrants when
they jump into things so that that's my
only concern and I think DeSantis is
pretty [ __ ] sadistic he's a little
sadistic to send someone off season to
the vineyard without giving them the
lecture that they should rent first
because you don't know where your summer
is going to be
I have friends in Malibu that would have
been happier if they stayed in Palos
Verdes it's just what it is
that's my my only concern for the
migrants
but that's again
that's where I'm at with this
everyone's like making a political it's
like it's inherently not political it's
about real estate and culture
everyone's like I left and right about
and understand this this has nothing to
do with Biden and DeSantis this has
everything to do with making good real
estate decisions